good morning millennials welcome back to
the toast happy Wednesday it is hump day
it is a bright and gorgeous morning
speaking from a girl who slept a good
chunk of time I'm a new woman hey Jax
can I introduce you to your new co-host
oh I'm so excited though I'm gonna miss
turdy Lou who do we have here today it's
it's Turtle it's dirty shoe no no by the
way yesterday was attorney Lou today is
turdy Lou yesterday was tourney Boo and
today is turning whoa
well I'm so glad to meet turdy Wu she
seems like an amazing woman and I'm so
glad that she doesn't have the Sim the
same struggles as turdy boo when I tell
you how much better I am like what sleep
can do and you know I like hated that I
was I was yesterday I was walking
through life I don't even remember doing
the show I don't remember what stories
and I hate that feeling of like feeling
like I didn't do a good job on the toast
but so many people enjoyed the anger I'm
you know we got good content out of it
our reels were popping off I feel like I
did my job because that's literally what
we do so I feel good but I'm ready to
dive back in like full attention I'm
excited about the stories I'm excited
about Jax I can't believe I was sitting
here complaining about sleep to a
pregnant woman who has a one-year-old
like that's me lack of self-awareness
that's okay I did get another morning of
waking up with my hatch and then like
two minutes later Harry woke up so it
was really amazing that hatch is really
something so far let's talk about that
has Harry I'm obsessed like I'm this is
definitely the longest I've gone without
seeing him like I I
I my blood boiling not okay he's great
he's ready for you he just you know
wants to play wants to sing wants to be
entertained and his favorite Entertainer
is not here
I am the Entertainer literally a week
from tomorrow I will see him I'm coming
to your house but like I don't even know
I'm gonna get no time with him because I
land super late do you think I could go
in and give him a kiss when I land
no it no because like he will wake up he
is the type and like Loki you can't kiss
a baby in a crib like that [__] is so
far down it's back-breaking work like
I'll have to go see my physical
therapist I'm pregnant putting him down
like especially when he's like sleeping
and I'm trying to like Place him it it
can't happen no like the one time I
tried to put him down recently um I he
was like he was sleepy he wasn't
sleeping he was in my arms I'm like
hurled over this crib my feet are
flailing off the side I like plopped him
in he hit his head and he started crying
it's terrible I actually always dream
like every night when I put him down I'm
like I need a [__] step stool that's
like under the Chris that's under the
crib that I could just like pull out
just like one step to make me taller and
then I just like push it back in that's
what you need yeah I think it every
night actually now that I'm not gonna
order one like right now because you
know has to go with the Aesthetics and
everything so
um oh wait a little a little update from
you know New York toast headquarters I
got a heating pad for the show wow and
it's kind of gorgeous it is making me
like kind of tired like warmth just
makes me tired yeah but it's so nice
because you know I want to sit up
straight when we do the toast I want to
have good posture but that like makes my
back hurt so I'm like here with my
heating pad I'm kind of loving it I
realized that sometimes in the reels I
look really like a big oaf because
throughout the episode I slide down into
the chair like I always start looking
really nice so then when I put when I
get my video and I'm like editing it I
always think I look really good but like
I don't really see the Middle where I'm
like a puddle yeah so I need to sit up
straighter during the toast if I want to
like the reels and if I want gen Z to
still like think highly of me oh my God
I know like are you starting to
consider gen Z like into your everyday
life like what will gen Z think no not
at all because I've had this success
with Gen Z just like being myself yeah
and they like me as I am I think if I
started pandering to them they would
sniff me out in a second no it's true
and that would kind of go against like
your relationship with them because up
until this point you've been kind of
like telling them the hard truths but
they love hard truths and that's why we
hope and that's why I love them it gives
me hope for the future it does so I just
I'm gonna keep doing my thing and gen Z
rides for Jackie oh it's a beautiful
thing uh my book club met last night and
I've realized like what my toxic trait
of book club is
foreign
don't please don't start guessing what
you think my toxic trait is
um I must seriously maybe minimum 10
times per book club meeting like bring
up you like I feel like everyone's like
my God shut up like either I'm talking
about like what the redheads do or oh
Jackie hated that book or Jackie thought
we should do this or and they're like I
feel like everyone's like my God
Jackie's not in this book club like [__]
off oh my what book did I hate
uh well not hate but we were coming up
with suggestions for next week and it's
Rachel's turn to pick and she we like to
have like two or three options because
it always turns out that somebody has
already read the book right so one of
her selections was the invisible life of
Addie LaRue and I know that's like a
Jackie I'll make you eyes Jackie loved
yeah it's a redhead's favorite it was so
good I just don't think you're gonna
like it did snitch like it
yeah we called it the invisible life of
snitchy LaRue okay I would read it like
I I would read it it's like midnight
library and you didn't oh such a bad
book I actually really don't think
you're gonna like Addie LaRue like okay
so like when I vote I'll vote for the
other one what is the other one about
I don't know but they both sounded like
decent yeah it's just if you didn't like
Midnight Library
I don't think you're gonna like Addie
LaRue it's a little it's also like
magical realism oh my God I oh I have to
tell everyone I hate magical realism and
it's like throughout history
is it famous couples throughout history
it's famous Addie throughout history got
it got it she's kind of like a solo
girly but that's like my toxic thing and
then you like send pictures of like
Harry in the bath so I was like guys
Jackie sent pictures of Harry and of
course everyone like got lit up for
Harry but I just felt like oh my God I
wonder how many times I've said Jackie
during oh and like two of our book club
members are pregnant so well Jackie said
like this and you're pregnant too I'm
like oh Jackie's also do that and like I
was like really being annoying that's so
funny I need to come to the next one oh
my God they would love okay are you in
town I'm trying to come into town in May
okay maybe if you um
if it lines up with your trip they would
love it and now whatever book you're
reading I'll read it too and like we
could participate a celebrity at our
book club they would oh my God they
would freak yeah
and like everyone knows you and like one
of the girls Marquel in my book club
like is for in your grade so it's always
just like I'm trying to keep everyone up
to date with like Jackie Tings yeah but
also like if not for the redheads
yeah that means you're walking in like
there might not be a book club so when
we first got started like some of our
founding members like we were really
kind of looking to the redheads for
guidance when it came to books and just
structure we do Hollywood treatment so
you're very much like a court you know
Cornerstone of the we need a name for
our book club
oh well what do you guys you guys have
like a home-cooked dinner yeah we always
even though like my turn to host is
coming up soon
um and like we are going to be ordering
in
oh but it's always like at someone's
house it's always it's very like Hamish
maybe it's like the potluck book club
yeah but it's not a potluck because one
person Cooks we give one person like all
the responsibilities like the dishes
um
and I love walking out with like a pile
of dishes and the sink I'm like see you
next month yeah because that's gonna be
you
no no I'm ordering it and we're using
plastic why don't you make Ben Cook that
could be his punishment I mean if
everybody ate Ben's Chili like they
would I would be they would ask me to
host every month oh I understand it's a
blessing and a curse
yeah you do need to come up with a name
yeah I'll think about it I mean I I
think we should definitely like the core
of the group like a lot of us went to
the same high school what about the
yellow belly book club
I love Jackie okay you guys when we were
in high school I had like a core group
of friends it was like 10 of us and you
know when you're in high school like you
have to like do something like to like
you know symbolize that you're all in a
group of friends and we got these yellow
they were so so [__] ugly these big
yellow Bangles what did they say on them
I don't know I think they were from
Dylan's Candy Bar like they were huge
thick chunky bright yellow Bangles with
like red writing on it but like we loved
them because you know only you know the
10 of us had them and Jackie used to
call us the yellow bellies because we
wore these yellow bracelets it was
actually hysterical and so most of the
people in your book club are former
yellow bellies or actually no or their
yellow belly adjacent they're yellow
belly adjacent but only Rachel is a
yellow belly like Abe was a guy so he
wasn't in the yellow bellies Margo I
know from college Raquel was two years
older like actually it's actually not a
yellow belly crew damn it would have
been the perfect name it would have even
though like nobody besides you and me
knew that you called us the yellow
bellies right but it didn't catch on but
if you just come up with a name for the
book club like that's a good catchy one
like the group will be like okay yeah
imagine you just like if you hadn't
brought up yellow bellies haven't
thought about that in Forever that's so
funny but that's like so you you were
always being like nickname girly Jackie
has always been this like original
creator of like you know turdy like it's
not surprising that you are who you are
I know I was just talking with my friend
Erica because she was asking me like why
we call snitch the snitch like where's
turd come from and I I literally had to
go through every iteration of like where
these things came from and it's
ridiculous it's it's inexplicable it
really is and now I've got a snitch a
turd and a trout and that's how I see
this I see like newt trout I see new
toasters being like can someone explain
origin of like snitch or turning and to
be honest it really doesn't matter just
know like I am 30 Margo is Snitch
Olivia's trout you know yeah and that
Margo is not a snitch like she does is
she's not called snitch because she's
she's not a big log of a duty and Olivia
is not a fish and she doesn't like
particularly like fish it's not like a
you know she likes fish she does but
it's that's not why you call her because
she's always eating fish no I call her
it because one time I was calling her
like Oliver because her name's Olivia
like that's no brainer and I got
confused and I thought Oliver twists the
orphan I thought his name was Oliver
trout so Oliver trout is something
no from the OC what's his last name okay
no okay hold on Oliver from the OC he's
Oliver t
Oliver from the OC is Trask
but who is Oliver trout your sister is
Oliver trout
okay wait like no like Oliver trout is
not a thing right I mean actually Oliver
trout on my LinkedIn is a sales
associate at Tuckahoe Bike Shop but
other than that
no so I I thought it was Oliver Trout
the orphan so I was like calling her
Oliver trout Antonette called her trout
and it wasn't until like I was already
calling her trout that I realized it's
Oliver Twist that's so funny maybe
Oliver Twist was asking may I have some
more please maybe he was asking for
church
probably not that was probably like
porridge it's always porridge sludge
mystery well it's Wednesday which is
such a good day here because we're
always in High Spirits we're halfway
through the week we've hopefully either
just come from humping someone we love
or we're going to hump someone we love
and we have deer toasters our weekly
advice segment which is just one of my
favorite parts of the week we've got
three really good submissions and we're
coming off of a high because last night
Jackie and I did a live podcast episode
which we've been doing once a month on
our patreon I thought last night was I
wouldn't even talk about it we never got
to recap because I rent a book club yeah
we I thought it was one of our best one
yeah we were so funny we were so funny
it's always so good and the time really
flies it's an hour-long live show
there's so much audience participation
we have like this outline that we always
actually wind up getting through but we
just go on a million tangents and it's
so much fun we just get to talk about
like everything and I think last night
was one of our most highly attended
events I know there was like almost 2
000 people watching live and then when I
got home 7 000 people had already
watched it wow so people were loving it
if you uh if you missed it you can still
watch it and if you want to join live
next month just become a patreon member
and you'll get all the the links and
everything sent straight to your patreon
app also or your email whatever it is so
that's patreon.com toast that was fun I
had a good time yeah I had a good time
too that was freaking Fred our virtual
live show that we do once a month live
show it's virtual live show it's virtual
lived
live show it's turning live show with
Jackson Claude
Papa
so good
so good okay so let's get into
everything because we have a lot to do
today a lot and we have good stories I'm
really excited about them yes I actually
chose like three of them because I'm
like so like on the pulse of Pop Culture
you're so in the nose without further
Ado here are the past five stories that
you need to know
and today's episode is brought to you by
droplet when we learned that 90 of your
skin care goes to waste because it gets
wiped or sweated off before absorbing to
your skin we were shook to say the least
that's why we're so excited to introduce
you to the new product that we've been
loving the droplet they're award-winning
handheld device transforms your serums
into a high velocity micro Mist that
absorbs into the skin 20 times deeper
than topicals
the device pairs with the droplet app to
unleash the most powerful deeply
penetrating results and it lets you
personalize your skincare routine with
targeted treatment modes like if you do
your skincare and then get into bed and
you lay on the side of your face and you
pull your face off your pillow you will
literally feel your skincare like coming
off and like laying on your pillow and
then you have like dirty pillows you
have to wash you just have more jobs
choose to see here's how it works you'll
choose the serum that best meets your
skin care needs and then you'll just
start misting droplet is really fun it's
easy to use and it delivers powerful
treatments in under 60 seconds morning
noon and night right from the comfort of
your own home it feels like a Mist but
it offers an injectable alternative
without needles pain or recovery it is
the ultimate self-care experience from
the comfort of your home the device
works with formulation capsules
basically like an espresso pod or like
when you're making coffee so you can use
it to infuse the treatments that are
right for you into your skin not just
onto your skin so it's really fun to do
it actually makes a lot of sense like I
I've always felt like right before bed
doing your skincare and then getting
into bed and I'm a very rough sleeper
I'm like how is this actually working
and when I use like skin care with
tanning I always know that so much of my
skincare has kind of like peeled off or
not absorbed because I have patches all
over my skin so this is a really great
device to make sure you're really
penetrating your skin with all of your
skin care for a limited time listeners
can get 50 off your droplet device at
droplet.io and use code toast that's
d-r-o-p-l-e-t-t-e dot i o code toast
today's episode is also brought to you
by Missouri so if you are looking for a
high quality beautiful jewelry that you
can really live in you've got to check
out Missouri because most people think
only about buying jewelry for special
occasions but Missouri does find jewelry
differently by celebrating every day not
just the big moments their high quality
pieces are designed for you to wear your
way whatever your taste your mood or
your or your budget Missouri drops new
limited edition products every Monday
so they feature responsibly sourced
Diamond recycled 14 carat solid gold
pieces that you can sweat shower and
sleep in that's what I love about
majority it's like I'm the type of
person I leave my jewelry on like my
core jewelry that I wear every day and
to have to take off necklaces and Rings
before you get in the shower or after
you wear them for a long time because
they like weirdly turn your skin green
so annoying it's another chore Missouri
jewelry is so well made it's so
beautiful it will not turn your skin
green and you can shower in it because
it's made really well so it's real
jewelry that you can live in their
designs are really classic so it feels
really good to invest in stuff that
you'll know you'll be wearing for a long
time so you can discover fairly priced
and expertly handcrafted styles to wear
and love forever at Missouri if you're
looking for a sign to buy yourself the
diamond or the gold hoops the bracelet
or the necklace then this is the sign or
if you're looking for someone in your
life to buy it for you send them to
missouri.com that's
m-e-j-u-r-i.com make your own day by
going to missouri.com thank you Missouri
for sponsoring today's episode I have so
many beautiful pieces for Missouri and
I've had them for quite a long time now
and they really have aged very well it's
not like I feel like a lot of jewelry
companies you have to start recycling
your jewelry like it doesn't
last more than a few months but majority
is on top of it
great thank you so much I'm right on top
of that Rose our first story Giselle is
on the cover of Vanity Fair looking
gorgeous and talking about her divorce
uh so the article itself I started to
read it and it's just like
too verbose about how she like picks up
an injured baby bird and like it was
just woof that is like that scene in
Something Borrowed where uh Steve Howey
the guy who plays I think his name is
Marshall he like picks up the ladies and
he always tells them about you know this
one time he really he grew up in empath
and he saw this injured bird and it's
like this recycled it's like such a
corny thing people say like we get it
you're sensitive like there are other
ways of showing that just listen to this
paragraph bun chin has just discovered
the unmoving robin nestled on a white
couch on her Terrace a serendipitous
Landing place with a panoramic Vista of
the beach below looking bereft she
Scoops the bird up with the ease of a
Disney princess taking care with its
mangled claw sounds like she wrote this
herself like it just sounds like this
person is in the wrong line of work
because the screen want the tea on
Giselle not the bird's Wing but she also
just did another cover
um
and it feels like both of them are like
Giselle like everything you need to know
and it's like well why wasn't it in the
first one well the other cover was
Italian Vogue Vogue and this is much
more like Gisele stripped down and she's
talking about her divorce and she's
debunking the rumor that it was about
football like it was not about the
football she said
um she told that in the affair in a
bombshell April 20 20 23 cover story
published on Wednesday that the former
couple split was much bigger than just
football when asked whether she gave Tom
an ultimatum their marriage or his job
she called the notion very hurtful and
the craziest thing she's ever heard oh
okay yeah she said she's always shared
for her now ex who retired in 2021 and
then walked back on his decision she
said quote if there's one person I want
to be the happiest in the world it's him
believe me I want him to achieve and to
conquer I want all his dreams to come
true clarifying that she is not somebody
who is against football she also claimed
that politics never made her pull the
plug on their marriage she called
successful relationships a dance and a
balance saying when I was 26 years old
and he was 29 years old we met we wanted
a family we wanted things together as
time goes by we realize that we just
wanted different things she noted that
their decision doesn't mean that they
don't love each other it just means that
in order for you to be authentic and
truly live the life that you want want
to live you have to have somebody who
can meet you in the middle
politics what is that I never heard that
and are either one of them extremely
political not that I know of but hers
just saying that thing at the end like
about you have to have someone who will
meet you in the middle like it does fan
those flames of like he didn't meet her
in the middle because he chose football
no I know I don't think she's
necessarily lying because maybe it
wasn't about football but like the you
know she could have had a problem with
his priorities
meaning you know
choosing to go back after he retired so
it's not it's not like she's mad about
football but she's mad about like you
know him not putting the family first
like it's not the football thing it's
always you know it's like it's what
we're always talking about it's like
it's not the dishes in the sink it's the
lack of respect yeah yeah so I feel like
she could be telling the truth I think
she is telling the truth and especially
when she calls it like the craziest
thing that she's ever heard it is like
pretty extreme but I'm sure also like if
he was choosing football in some areas
like he was probably often times making
choices that weren't family-centric
though he didn't seem like a family man
yeah and Bridget Moynihan has always
spoken very highly of him as like a
father and a family man so maybe it's
not that but maybe it's like in choosing
football like he's choosing living in
Tampa and like that's not the best thing
for their family because she lives in
Costa Rica now with the kids yeah that's
where she is she's also seen in Miami
sometimes and they said she's dating
some like
businessman billionaire bow oh thank God
somebody's finally taking our advice and
I think his name is Mr software
oh my God okay so I'm so glad you
brought that up
so his name is Jeffrey Soffer and if you
live in Miami you know that name he owns
the fountain blue Hotel like he's a big
big developer
um and Ben actually has an uncle named
Jeffrey Soffer but it's not him no no
and when Ben like so if you if you grew
up like in like a the Jewish scene like
everybody went to Miami for Passover it
was like The Hot Spot during high school
like you would see everyone you know and
Ben used to stay at the fountain blue
and he used to get like crazy special
treatment because his last name was
software but there's quite and spelled
the exact same way there's literally no
relation Ben was like so young able to
get ever so the fountain blue hotel has
the club live which is like one of the
biggest clubs in all of Miami Ben used
to be able to get all these kids in he's
like hi and Ben's offer my dad is Bruce
and I actually think the other Jeffrey
Soper has a brother named Bruce and
Ben's dad Bruce has a brother named
Jeffrey like it's crazy there was like
and when I tell you there's literally no
relation but there were so many like
similarities eventually The Jig read up
but Ben was running this scam for like
five years during Passover time in Miami
and he was like the coolest kid on the
Block what if all this time like we
thought Ben has the benefact but it's
really just people thinking he's related
to Jeffrey Soffer
I don't think that's it what I think it
is it's like that those formative years
in Miami where Ben was kind of treated
special for who they thought he was kind
of gave Ben the drive and the
connections
thus resulting in what we now know as
the benefit do you think it also
resulted in the entitlement that led him
to use a flashlight at 4 30 a.m can of
beans for his wife for weeks on end I do
um
like someone put away his beans yeah
Jackie Nothing in life is an accident
you know we're all like a connect
everything everyone's life is a
connection a series of moments and so
Ben is the man and the person that he is
because of those formative years spent
as Jeffrey soffer's quote unquote nephew
Jeffrey Savers Ward right so everything
we know about Ben
is a direct result of kind of the
monster he was made into in Miami in
those early 2000s wow how are you and
Ben have you forgiven him by the way so
funny I was I think I don't know if I
said this oh I think I said this
Unbreaking bread last night like I for
the last week I feel like I've come on
here and like dragged Ben between the
chili the flashlight Ben saw for a
celebrity like every episode our titles
have all been about Ben
you would never know like at home I'm
such a doting wife and Ben's been
traveling a lot so like I'm not gonna
like be mad at him still while he's
traveling and like I miss him and I love
him I just like love to use him for
content and father and everything is
true but I'm not I'm not mad even though
this morning we Face times and he was
like how are you feeling I'm like I'm
like a lot better since flashlight gate
yeah but I'm not I'm not actually mad
got it okay that's good that's
surprising though
yeah no I know because I can hold a
grudge with the best of them yes all the
people in my life you're really like so
you're soft You're So Soft with Ben it's
crazy it's like we know you as this
tough [__] yep and if anyone else
pulled half the ship in is pulled even
in the last like year 24 hours I
wouldn't talk to them yeah no you're
real softy when it comes to bed that's a
fun fact about turdy Lou that I would
never expect and like every time I hear
it I'm shocked like when she said like
oh no Ben and I were on the phone the
key King I miss him I was like
so you don't hate him no I know it's
shocking but like I low-key love him
like and I you know that's so sweet it's
the truth yeah but he is great for
Content oh my God here he was going to
sue the toast for defamation
good he should first of all we'll get so
much press and he'll lose because
nothing I said was a lie in order to you
know win a defamation case which is
extremely difficult you have to prove
that the person was lying I have photo
evidence of the beans
I have yesterday's episode to prove I
was clearly up at 4 30. clearly
no lies we're told
damn
okay well speaking of court cases our
next story oh
Gwyneth Paltrow is an Utah at court for
the first day of a Civil Trial brought
against her
over by a retired optometrist Terry
Sanderson over a ski accident in 2016.
is optometrist eyes
I think so yeah I just saw like a funny
Tick Tock of like the world's leading
optometrist doing a panel about you know
the benefits of laser eye surgery or
Lasik
um and every single one of them was
wearing glasses
stop yeah so it's like well why didn't
you get it or maybe they did get it but
it does start to dwindle the effects
dwindle after many many years I just
thought it was interesting that's funny
ever since dope sick I'm like hella
sauce
yeah but though I've heard laser eye
surgery is just miraculous for those who
need it like I yeah I'm privileged in
the sense that I've never known when
it's like to wake up and not and have to
reach for my classes me too and like
clatter around yeah yeah or like have to
put contacts in my eyes every single day
but for the people who have done the
surgery like Dana just did it like uh
two years ago oh my God she doesn't
she's still talking about it it's the
best thing she ever did in her whole
life it's literally life-changing
life-changing I think snitch wants to do
but I think Olivia should do it too I
think Olivia should do it too Olivia's
eyes are really bad Olivia's been like
you know clattering for her glasses like
since she was a youngin since we were
quite literally like six yeah she did
start wearing contacts really early in
life and she's kind of in a contact
Queen but it's time to level up it's
time to level up that's a good birthday
gift for somebody like to schedule them
and like get them Lasik eye surgery yeah
Kylie got it recently her and stuff yeah
yeah yeah yeah they were so excited yeah
okay anyways Gwyneth is on trial and she
will be testifying as will her husband
Brad falchuk and both of her kids apple
and Moses in this ski accident trial so
basically this man they were all skiing
in Deer Valley Resort in February 2016.
there was a ski collision between
Gwyneth and the optometrist the
optometrist says that it was a hit and
run that Gwyneth got him from behind
knocked him out and he suffered severe
injuries and she kept on skiing then
Gwyneth was with a ski instructor the
ski instructor filed a report saying
that it wasn't gwyneth's fault like he
reported the accident but the
optometrist is saying it's a false
report and he was suing Gwyneth for 3.1
million dollars in Damages you know
brain trauma physical stuff you know
quality of life never gonna be the same
again Gwyneth is maintaining that one
this guy caused the accident and two
he's doing this extorting her Fame and
her wealth Etc can I ask you a question
though because I don't ski and so I
don't know what the legalities are or
what like you know what are the rules
but let's say even it was her fault like
she you know didn't see him and knocked
into him is that not just like an
occupational hazard of skiing like we're
all that's why I don't ski I'm always
hearing about like crazy skiing
accidents like isn't that just like you
chose to get on a mountain like isn't
that just like a a potential Hazard of
being a skier yeah
but like if someone does injure you you
do have the right to sue them but also
it's a hit and run aspect that she like
hit him he was injured and she didn't
wait for help or try and help him it's
the same thing with you know you could
get into a car accident it's like if you
hit and run like it's a much bigger
crime than an accident that's true okay
but also if she did severely injure him
wouldn't she have been injured too like
you can't just like if you knock into
someone that's you're both being it
could go either way like okay you could
knock someone over they have a bad fall
and you manage to catch yourself oh God
there's all different variations of what
could happen so Gwyneth will be taking
the stand during the trial and her
attorney said in opening statement that
Brad falchuk will and her kids who were
9 and 11 at the time they were on a
family ski trip like Gwyneth is really
just like putting everything behind
maintaining her innocence that this man
is like some extortionist I mean I have
to assume
she probably has a decent case because
this is so public and she has so much
money like it might be you know more
less less worry for her to have just
paid this guy all those years ago you
know yeah also I'm pretty sure the judge
capped it at 300 000 for even if he wins
like it's not gonna be three million
dollars so she would have just settled
with him out of court if she was really
in the wrong yeah but I also I mean I
don't know Gwyneth and I feel like I'm
just spending more on lawyers than 300
000. yeah I'm basing this off of like
her character in the politician but I
really feel like if she ran collided
with someone like she would she would
stop and help them let me tell you how
one of my also a ski instructor would so
that is their job is to patrol the
slopes like they were on a beginner's
course you don't just like leave someone
there right of course there could be
corruption the sea instructors
protecting Gwyneth but like it's a ski
accident let me tell you how one of my
ever since I met Gwyneth Paltrow like
one of my missions in life is to let
people know like how wrong they are
about her
um she is quite literally the nicest
woman you've ever met in your life she's
so not what you think and I feel like of
all celebrities like she has this crazy
image of like what people think about
her just given the fact that she's like
a nepo baby she has this like wellness
Empire that's like kind of out of touch
like it's not relatable to like a lot of
people and I think people really feel
like they know her and when I first met
her and I was around her and her kids I
was like Shook at the woman in front of
me like she reminded me so much of like
just a mom she was like obsessed with
her kids like like kissing like it was
just she was so normal she was so loving
she was so interested in what other
people were saying when you meet
celebrities it's always like no one else
is talking it's just them them them and
it's actually kind of boring to be
around celebrities because like I want
to talk about myself
she was asking so many questions about
like what I do like everyone at the
table she was like what is your
relationship like she was so gracious
and so loving and I've just really
always felt like she was so
misunderstood and I think in recent
years like people have definitely gotten
to know her a little bit better but I
still feel like people really don't know
her and you're right like her character
is not that character of someone who
would literally assault someone even by
accident and then move on she's like an
empath she has compassion like she's a
mother she would never like that's just
and that's just my own I have no proof
of this and I'm definitely biased
because I feel like I really um like
he's my Guinness but you haven't met
Terry Sanderson right so I'm I'm just
saying based on my own and I feel like
everyone in this life should make
judgments based on their own experience
with people not what they think or what
they read I really believe she's like a
a wonderful person
that's really really nice to hear and I
also feel like if she were in part
responsible for this and it's more of
what he said than what she said she
would not be putting her children on the
stand to testify in her defense
especially when they were nine and
eleven it's like remember that thing
that happened when you were nine can you
go and lie about it for me no 100
especially when her kids up until this
point are very private like they don't
have like you know crazy social media
followings they're not Apple has started
now that she's like I think 16 or 17.
she started to like maybe go to events
but they're not like crazy public
figures yeah
yeah I also had seen a headline I knew I
should have
opened the tab for this story because I
was going to reference it that in
Discovery I guess it's come out that the
guy texted his daughter after the
Collision saying like I'm gonna be
famous oh oh but I need to find it
because I only saw the headline it was
on The Daily Mail and now of course I
can't oh well he wasn't wrong he is
famous now oh wait okay a screener and a
Facebook status saying I'm famous
uh
that's that's not good that's a negative
in his column yeah where's the Facebook
status
I don't know that's a negative in his
column for sure but then there's also a
witness who was like the witness on the
slopes who said it was gwenna's fault
this is just a classic case literally of
he said she said it is and so the court
shall decide but I also feel like there
are
companies that can do like mock
collisions based on you know the slope
where he was responsibility his weight
and see like are the injuries sustained
that by him are they
do they coincide with his tale of things
or not I'm sure gwyneth's people have
you know the the right teams putting
together those sort of mock accidents
things yeah
this is interesting and so of course
people on the internet are now saying
that last week when it's drama with her
podcast was very intentional she put
that out so people would talk about that
as opposed to this which quite literally
makes no sense I hate that's how like I
know people don't understand like
celebrity culture because they're always
saying like the Kardashians put this out
so we're not talking about that when has
that ever stopped people on the internet
from talking about something it's so
dumb and why would Gwyneth put herself
intentionally in a negative light
knowing this thing is coming up would it
be like well she's obviously a bad
person look at this part like it's right
so it wasn't like that was good press
right that made you feel more warmly
towards Gwyneth if anything it's like if
she were going to a soup kitchen last
week I'd be like oh well that's clearly
intentional that's clearly you know to
nullify the effects of what we're about
to see I hate when people say that and
sometimes that is what happens and I
agree but people have just like taken
that notion so far they're always saying
that well like maybe they're putting
this out to distract us from that and
it's like that stuff actually happens
but the way you're saying it that makes
no sense why would quen like the people
saying it for the guinea thing is quite
literally the dumbest thing yeah that's
not how it works no that's not how any
of this works literally
okay well are you ready for our next
story yeah some happy couple news Dylan
Sprouse is engaged to Barbara Palvin
after five years of dating I'm obsessed
with these two yeah I forgot I was
worried for a second that they weren't
still together because I hadn't heard of
them in so long but that's a good sign
like it is it is but usually you know
you see pics and they are also very like
aesthetic so I would always stuff comes
up like an explore page I don't follow
he's like a photographer yeah yeah
they're always just like doing things
but
um he popped the question to Barbara
Palvin his longtime girlfriend A source
told Entertainment Tonight on Tuesday
that Dylan and Barbara are engaged they
have been showing off her ring to people
and are so happy they're always very in
love with one another and by each
other's sides but they're even happier
than usual they can't wait to start this
next chapter together
I like love these two as a couple ever
since they started I have stand they're
so well matched and I never would have
even like how did these two even you
know end up in the same room like it's
so random but they're so good looking
Zach what's his name Zach I'm saying
Zach and Cody uh Dylan is so handsome
like he really grew up to be such a
handsome young man she is so next level
like Perfection like I honestly if I
could look like anyone she's definitely
on like my top 10 list of people I would
want to look like and they're so in love
they're so low-key they've been together
for so long I was I was like genuinely
happy for them when I heard the snooze
yeah me too
nothing but good news and it's nothing
but good nice things to say so the
conversation the story is short but it's
also so weird when you think about how
different the Sprouse Brothers ended up
in their careers because you would have
thought like you know with with
Riverdale and then that really was like
this Resurgence of Cole Sprouse like if
anything like Cole was out here winning
because Zach doesn't really act
um he's much more low-key has like a
beverage company right he's not as
currently you know famous in the typical
sense but
um he stays winning too yeah and I love
it I really do I'm so and I feel like
his relationship with Barbara people are
obsessed with so he's like kind of
stayed in you know in terms of relevance
in the Limelight because of that and
when she was at the Victoria's Secret
Fashion Show he was there like it was
just so cute
so cute
and then it also just reminded me we
never got to talk about Cole Sprouse on
caller Daddy I didn't watch the
interview but I saw the highlights and
the smoking the cigarette yeah the
cigarette honestly I never thought much
about Cole Sprouse like
ever
um and having seen just even the this
few clips from his interview I know for
a fact like we would not like each other
like on a personal life
he was giving cringe I mean like smoking
inside is something you have to be
extremely cool to do and he's not cool
in that way and after the interview he's
probably less cool than I thought he was
just even how he holds the cigarette
like it was just it was cringe it was
giving cringe I would have had more
respect for him if he started to vape
honestly like and also just the way that
he talks he's so serious he's so verbose
like he's obviously very smart and
educated and I think that if you can sit
through what he's trying to say he's
probably saying something and making a
point but it is word salad but it's big
word salad yeah big words I went to NYU
at the same time as Dylan and Cole
they're very well educated yeah but you
don't sound like that turdy Lou why not
not at all it's because I was trying to
get like famous on Instagram throughout
College well uh Cole was actually
studying I remember people used to like
know a lot about them because they were
like the celebrities on campus he was
studying archeology like he's very uh
he's like a curious person yeah which is
good and I do feel like that's really
not something that you can fake yeah or
you can but like he didn't sound like
dumb he just sounded pompous pompous and
like um
condescending
yeah and it's just like he is relatively
young like you don't have all the
answers but you sound like someone who
does oh my God that's that's that's
exactly what it was it was cringe like
the whole thing was really cringe
especially the smoking yeah rude I think
she like films in her house like it's
rude no it's not her house but it's like
a house and that's and then she has this
video and yeah and like those chairs are
buccal like they absorb smells totally
but I think they smoke pot in there
sometimes too oh you're right but pot
really is different like cigarette
smells like and and the fumes like they
get into the walls I'm always seeing
people on Tick Tock cleaning like these
people who are like expert cleaners
going into homes of people who have
passed away who smoked in their house
for 30 years and like the black [__]
that comes out of people's like walls
and air vents is like nothing you've
ever seen in your life Furniture it
really it's like tar yeah now I'm just
trying to think about like smoking on
podcasts like on Joe Rogan they smoke
cigars a lot but that's a studio maybe
they have proper ventilation it doesn't
yeah they smoke pot too and like Joe is
smoking too so it's it's okay I'm sure
he was like she's not gonna say no I
don't know if anyone I've not seen the
Joe work in the episode where someone
was smoking a cigarette but I've not
watched even close like I am sure 100
somebody has they probably have to have
people come in and clean those curtains
and the carpets because that [__] get
gets into fabric yeah and then I'm sure
there's people who like Jewel
which is I think it doesn't leave any
after effects on furniture totally fine
but just like people like might make fun
of you depending on how you're doing it
but I think I would make more fun of at
least in the cold situation it was so
uncool in terms of like aesthetic he
should have Vaped yeah
yeah but I guess if you're a person who
interviews a lot of celebrities it would
behoove you to have like a stock if I if
I was Alex Cooper like you know Joe
Rogan and I had like a celebrity coming
into my studio every week and I I would
have probably like a stockpile of a pot
of cigarettes of Vapes of cigars like
and liquor obviously like for whatever
anybody needs because everybody is
always if you really want to get them
comfortable I think they do yeah they do
so yeah that was that was funny that was
cringe um are you ready for our next
story yeah Sophia Coppola's daughter
Romy is going viral because she was
grounded for trying to Charter a
helicopter nepo babies they're just like
us the eldest daughter of acclaimed
filmmaker Sophia Coppola 16 year old
Romy just revealed in a totally
unrelatable yet hilarious Tick Tock that
she was grounded for attempting to rent
a chopper using her musician father's
credit card so hey she was taking the
chopper she said because she wanted to
go have dinner with her Camp friend yeah
I saw and so she was grounded for such
so the video she like is talking in Fast
Forward mode and she says make a vodka
sauce with pasta with me because I'm
grounded because I tried to Charter a
helicopter from New York to Maryland on
my Dad's credit card because I wanted to
have dinner with my Camp friend
um she goes on to disclose that she
didn't know the difference between
garlic and an onion so she had to Google
images of onions on her phone she also
said um she's gonna do this and she's
already grounded and her parents biggest
rule is like she's not allowed to have
any public social media platforms but
she didn't think she'd be getting famous
from this Tick Tock right she's like No
One's Gonna care
um she I thought that was interesting
that like having uh no public social
media is like a ruin her house and she
said it was because her parents don't
want her to be a nepo baby even though
her mother is quite literally the
definition of an EPO baby well that's so
maybe that's exactly why she didn't want
that for her daughter
I guess but like she's reaping the
benefits why can't roommate yeah but
also she's 16. like that is really young
and because she is of note and her
parents are of no like everything she
does is going to be looked at so
critically literally she puts out one
look at this and we have a microscope
and it's fill of tea and like the girl
doesn't even know like the gems that
she's spewing because she just like
lives on a different planet I know and
for me I know people had a lot of
takeaways from this but like for me I'm
so curious what camp she goes to oh my
God that's funny if anybody has any
insight just DM me I won't share it
because that's [__] weird but I'm
just like [__] curious yeah but now
she's 16 she's not in Camp anymore she
would be like waiting to become a
counselor counselor yeah yeah yeah so
she still has cam friends I was just
curious like you know back in the day
there was like a camp scene we went to a
few different camps everybody knew of
the different camps so I'm just curious
now like where are the cool kids going
to camp
yeah that's what I want to know yeah
uh so who knows has been deleted for
Sophia Coppola's daughter Romy if the
tick tock has been deleted
she's also gorgeous of course gorgeous
gorgeous and we got we got um a little
insight into her babysitter
babysitter's boyfriend boyfriend yeah
she said this is Ari or whatever my
babysitter's boyfriend which I thought
was interesting like I guess you're the
babysitter when you're 16. it's a like
no you babysit when you're 16 maybe it
was just like her
I think babysitter's probably like an
affectionate term that she uses for
whoever is the person who's like home
with her but it honestly I maybe she's
like a a problematic child she's already
grabbed I've been chartering a
helicopter by yourself she's not the
type of 16 year old who you would leave
alone I guess yeah
some 16 year olds are like really
responsible and very you know they have
jobs maybe she's not just not one of
those
yeah
it's just like a completely funny
Tick Tock it's almost like if Sophia
Coppola directed a tick tock video a
hundred like even the the babysitter's
boyfriend he talked about the helicopter
fiasca because it's a feminine Fiasco
oh by the way because it's women's
History Month
I also now know something I didn't know
which is that Sophia Coppola is married
to the lead singer of Phoenix
cool I didn't know that but is that her
dad yeah oh wow
that's nice I know that's really nice
yeah she holds up the Grammy in the
video too right which I guess is from
her dad yeah
does your mom have any Oscars I don't
think so I don't no no no no no no
Bling Ring wasn't winning any Oscars no
and like not that many female directors
have ever won Oscars oh that's true it's
a very short list and we wouldn't know
if she was on it yeah you're right
so that's what's going on with Romy I
hope that her grounding and soon but I'm
imagining that it just got extended uh
Beyond they're freaking the thing is so
the internet shockingly has received
this video really well like people are
kind of obsessed so it's not like she
tarnished a family name true but she did
break the family Rules no she broke her
parents rules like no matter who you are
like that gets you grounded yeah but
like if she broke the rules and like did
something crazy scandalous and like got
herself in trouble and like photographed
at a club like tarnish the family name
or like did this video and it was like
so poorly received and it was like this
girl ah like yeah I think it would be
even worse for mystery you're right
you're right if anything it's
it's giving people a fondness towards
the Coppola crew it it is it's cute it's
cute
are you ready for our fifth and final
story someone who is not acting cutely
oh Nick Lachey has been ordered to
attend Inger management classes in
Alcoholics Anonymous meetings nearly a
year after he accosted a female
photographer who was snapping pictures
from her car
veteran celebrity photographer but I
thought you were going to say just like
a man on the street like no uh Papa he
you know was aggressive with a Paparazzi
female Paparazzi
paparazza a lot of celebrities have
I've been there he was drunk and I guess
she pressed charges and he didn't get
any um
jail time jail time but it has to go to
anger management and AAA in exchange
also the photographer said that Nick
still hasn't apologized until this day
Nick hasn't taken any responsibility
he's Justified it he thought this was
done but it's not done
I mean to me this is so different than
like you know
it's not like this woman was doing
nothing to him like Paparazzi is very
invasive it's really bad for a lot of
people's mental health so it wasn't like
completely one-sided of course you
should never physically hurt anyone
especially a woman but um to me this
really doesn't tarnish my image of Nick
Lachey like to me this is just he had a
bad day and like
it's a part of being a celebrity it's
like getting mad at a Paparazzi yeah the
video shows him approaching the
paparazza's car and reaching through the
reaching through the window attempting
to snatch her phone and spewing
profanities she said that like she
rolled up her window really quickly
which she was relieved that she did
otherwise he would have knocked me out
no doubt about it okay well you have
literally no proof of that um sounds
like she actually didn't get assaulted
she just got her phone snatched which is
hella dramatic to take to court and if
now knowing what I know team Nick whoa
that's not what I thought you were gonna
say today paparazzis are always out here
like baiting people and then playing the
victim
yeah wow like no that this is not uh she
was not assaulted getting her phone
snatched it's wrong
and say like arms through the window you
know and then the window I don't know
what he would have done well neither do
we because you closed the window so case
closed yeah but it did sound like he got
an arm in there and he didn't knock you
out he just wanted the phone the phone
like
drama drama for what oh my God I really
was not expecting us to be defending
Nick Lachey today
you do I thought it was going to be like
Jessica was right no trash I have moved
on like I have moved on from Nick and
Jess I think they both have two I think
they were so young in her book like she
really dragged him to filth and like
embarrassed him and you know what he was
human he was young he was famous and
then he ended up marrying someone who
became more famous than him and he got
jealous because he had a big ego because
he was young like I don't think he's a
bad person I really don't okay
you don't think he's an angry person who
needs anger management I really don't
like and I think there the proof is in
the life he has with Vanessa Lachey like
it was really unfortunate it was
unfortunate the timing because we were
all standing him and Jess but like
he is a family man he's a loyal husband
he works hard he's maintained a really
nice career Love is Blind is the best
thing that ever happened to him but like
I don't know how can I really be mad at
Nick Lachey for real and I feel like Jim
and Jessica both publicly said that they
like squashed it they sent baby gifts
and then Vanessa was like I never got a
gift but like you know what I mean like
I feel like it's good okay yeah no I
agree I do agree with everything you
said I don't Harbor even though you know
I stand Jessica she's my birthday twin I
don't Harbor any hate in my heart for
Nick Lachey and that's because I believe
that Jessica doesn't
they're both so happy and successful and
in love yeah it was the best thing for
him they were so young yeah and
Jessica's like more happy and more
successful so that's good
uh definitely more successful you know
you can't measure happiness no
so those are the past five stories and
now for dear toasters I'm so excited
dear toasters Our advice segment is
brought to you by a new sponsor which
I'm so excited about because I use all
the time game time so the game time app
you guys buying tickets to your favorite
events should not be stressful and game
time is the fast and easy way to buy
tickets for all the sports music comedy
and theater near you with killer deals
on last minute tickets and their best
price guarantee you can stop stressing
over tickets and start getting hyped for
the fun you'll have I just like a few
months ago bought tickets to Billy Joel
like the night of on game time it's a
fabulous app and one of my favorite
things is that when you're buying your
tickets they let you see the like
virtual seat view from your seat so you
really have all the knowledge before
buying the tickets so you don't have to
plan months in advance which is
something we never do here at the toast
game time has deals on tickets right up
to the day of the event get exclusive
Flash Deals on tickets for football
baseball uh basketball concerts comedy
theater and more the game time guarantee
means that you'll always get the best
price so if you find tickets in the same
section and the same Row for Less game
time will credit you the difference
so get images of the seats before you
buy which is one of my favorite Parts
about the app you can buy tickets a
matter of seconds and tickets are sent
directly to your phone so you never have
to dig through your email so helpful
it's really like 21st century ticket
purchasing snag the tickets without the
stress with Game Time download the game
time app create an account and use code
toast for 20 off your first purchase
terms apply again create an account on
the game time app
g-a-m-e-t-i-m-e redeem uh 20 off with
code toast on the game time app and I
feel like in New York every night
there's something fabulous if you're
going on a date or with the girls and
you need something download game time
it's great for like event Discovery and
then also getting like the best possible
tickets for the best possible price
um all sent straight to your phone
today's episode is also brought to you
by betterhelp so thank you better help
for sponsoring today's episode Getting
to Know Yourself can be a lifelong
process especially because we're always
growing and changing therapy is all
about deepening your self-awareness and
understanding because sometimes we don't
know what we want or why we react the
way we do until we talk through things
that our help connects you with a
licensed therapist who can take you on a
journey of self-discovery from wherever
you are so if you're thinking of
starting therapy give betterhelp a try
it's done entirely online it's designed
to be convenient flexible and suited to
your schedule just fill out the brief
questionnaire and get matched with a
licensed therapist and switch therapist
anytime for no additional charge so
there's so many benefits from therapy
um and I think one of the hardest parts
about therapy is finding the right you
know therapist who matches with you and
it can be so discouraging to like make
the appointment sit in the waiting room
go to the office and then find out that
it's not a match and better help being
done all exclusively online makes it so
easy to like find the right person for
you and then it's just so much more
convenient for doing it from your phone
you can chat you can video you can call
you can text
um it makes it that much more accessible
and um
I feel like that questionnaire that you
fill out makes it really effective in
finding you a therapist who you're going
to Vibe with from the start so you can
discover your potential with better help
visit betterhelp.com toast today to get
10 off your first month that's
betterhelp
h-e-l-p.com slash toast betterhelp.com
toast and you'll get 10 off your first
month of better help better
h-e-l-p.com slash toast all right are we
ready for dear toasters we're ready
again if you ever want to write in our
email is deertoesters gmail.com we will
read your prompt on air but we will of
course leave your name out it's totally
Anonymous and you know Jackson Claude
are going to do their best with with
what you've got you know we sometimes we
give Tough Love sometimes it's the
things you don't want to hear but
sometimes the thing it's the thing you
need to hear
all right good morning Jackson clerd I
have a dilemma and I need your advice my
husband and I have one car and he drops
me off at work I use the Alexa alarm
that gradually wakes me up um because
waking up has always been difficult for
me recently my husband has been turning
my alarm off without my knowledge and
blames me for making a slate he doesn't
wake me up after he's turned off the
alarm or anything while he's like in the
shower he just expects me to wake up
magically I told him I need this type of
alarm in order to wake up in a timely
manner and not hold us both up do I tell
him to lay off or should I start just
using a different type of alarm no
honestly I feel like this is the best
time you could have asked this question
try the hatch yeah because the way that
it works and I'll have a code soon
because I'm clapping with them for the
redheads sorry toast like it's okay
eating podcast
um the way that it works is like it they
30 minutes before your alarm is supposed
to go off they start this light that is
supposed to be like the Sun so uh you
know 30 minutes before it's just like a
little light and by the time you're
supposed to wake up it's this really
bright light and you you don't even
realize that it's woken you up so the
last two days I woke up a few minutes
before my alarm and then by the time my
alarm went off I was like oh okay I can
get out of bed and I've always been a
snoozer always yeah and I intentionally
set my hatch alarm to make wake me up
earlier than I need to be up because I
would like to have extra time and I
still didn't snooze usually if I set my
alarm for earlier that's just more time
to snooze yeah I think that might just
be like a really easy solve here right
no I completely agree but also turning
off someone's alarm and not waking them
up is the next level psychotic it is but
some people like just are people who
wake up when they wake up and they they
open their eyes and they get out of bed
and it's not very hard for them so he
might not like understand how impossible
that is for you right it's impossible
for me too and if someone turns off my
alarm I've turned off my alarm in my
sleep and not even known oh that's the
worst completely slept through it and
been like did my phone malfunction yeah
that is the absolute worst I'm the type
of person I need a full 30 minutes
minimum to get out of bed the hatch is
30 minutes
once I'm like fully awake I need 30
minutes
I'm tell turdy Lou like I've always been
that person but is your room really dark
yeah
mine's not that dark it's dark but um
there's doors to our bathrooms which
have natural light so like the light
comes in when the sun comes up but it's
not com I feel like a hatch check
wouldn't make a difference on my eyes
because my room is like fairly bright no
turdy Lou like
it does I didn't even I didn't even
notice it until I and I was sleeping
facing the other way and like behind me
the hatch is bright but it somehow woke
me up like the Hatcher knows what it's
doing by the way I'm this is not
sponsored at all like I'm down to try
but my room is bright I can't see like
how effective it would be if the room is
already like there's this huge orb next
to you
I'll try it you're making sound really
good waking up is just so hard like I'll
try anything yeah no waking up like if I
could nail like my morning routine and
like get up before Harry like be a human
being and like get my coffee and not
just be like scrambling all morning my
life would be enhanced and so far I'm
two for two days and uh do you feel like
it's made a difference in your
productivity and everything
I don't yeah like not productivity
because like it's I'm still you know on
at his behest right but like it's so
much nicer waking up on my own instead
of like because of the crying and then
I'm like right you know I can like brush
my teeth in peace I weighed myself
having did you use your tongue scraper
no wow so I I got my tongue scraper it's
really nice in the evenings and it's fun
in the mornings like when I brush my
teeth in the morning every morning when
you're pregnant you will gag while you
brush your teeth I had a feeling you
were gonna it's hard for the course and
the part where you gag is the part where
you brush your tongue and so I did the
tongue scraper yesterday morning and it
was so gaggy and even when I was like
making my coffee like I still was having
like tongue gagginess oh that's too bad
because it's so much better in the
morning I know but I used it in the
evening and I liked it and did you get a
lot of Schmutz yeah yeah yeah isn't it
crazy it's more than you think right
yeah it's just like a bunch like
it's a little bit like Placebo it's
because it's also saliva but Okay no
Okay I really wish you would do it in
the morning because it's like chunky ew
and I did it yesterday morning and it
wasn't enough to make me withstand the
gag oh my God I like literally that's
one thing that's getting me out of bed
is my excitement to see what's on my
tongue well sorry to make your deer
toasters about us but um oh right hatch
restore too like try it out I know I'm
like really new to it but I'm two for
two yeah by the way that's actually
really good advice and I'd be like I'm a
bear like I just want to sleep all day
long but make your boyfriend pay for it
because this is his problem yeah yeah
and just tell them to wait till Jackie
has a code for you
totally all right next up Tony Lou and
Jackie O
the toast is one of the highlights of my
day I feel like you're the older sisters
I never got and I'm currently in need of
some big CIS advice
I recently got off birth control because
I found out I have low levels of
fertility shout out to Modern fertility
for getting this combo started for me
love that shout out this is also not
sponsored I am Consulting a local local
doctor to help me as I'm not ready to
have kids yet but I want to be proactive
so I can't have a family one day the
first step was to get off birth control
my boyfriend of over a year has been so
supportive and understanding during this
time but now that I'm off my birth
control my hormones are whack I am
constantly feeling repulsed by anything
this man does a simple fart puts me over
the edge I now feel like he's lazy he's
gross and annoying before I got off
birth control I was madly in love with
the occasional annoyance I can't tell if
it's the hormones or am I at the Mark
where the honeymoon stage is over do I
talk to my doctor about this do I sit
down with my boyfriend and tell him how
he's currently making me feel I don't
want to make any rash decisions if it's
only temporary and I don't want to hurt
my boyfriend's feelings help you need
time on this like you have to see your
hormones have not settled yet like
you've been on birth control for many
years you don't want to make a hormonal
decision I would just talk to your
doctor and ask like when your hormones
will level out and you'll like not be
feeling so hormonal do not break up with
your boyfriend in a huff don't even have
like a conversation with him because
this could be like a completely new
thing but like what if all this time
like hormonal birth control was the
patriarchy like trying to get women to
like be okay with their boyfriend's
disgusting habits oh and then you go off
of it and you see them for what they
really are which is which is ugly Jackie
you've cracked the code
that is definitely what's going on like
big Pharma just pushing women into like
complacency yeah to not noticing and
just being okay with like men's terrible
habits and right and not requiring men
to do better and you know reach their
potential instead let's change how the
women see them let's level out their
hormones so it doesn't bother them it's
literally Josie and the Pussycats like
they're putting subliminal messaging in
the music yeah they're putting
subliminal messaging into the birth
control you're so right yeah oh my God
we're on but in terms of in terms of
this girl's actual problem like
definitely wait and if by the time your
hormones have settled you realize like
maybe this was like actually a problem
in your relationship then you can tackle
it but I feel like for right now we
could chalk this up to like just being
you know out of sorts yeah right now out
of sorts but you know if in a long time
like maybe you were just like
emotionally mentally like coasting
because you know hormones were being
kept at Bay I don't know but I would not
make any permanent rash decisions while
you are ready relating from I feel like
it can take months to regulate yes
depending on how long you were on it so
give yourself a good chunk of time and
then let's revisit it okay how about
that yeah and ask your doctor like when
you can expect to be feeling like your
original Self again yeah and there's
doctor patient confidentiality so you
could like tell her what's going on yeah
but I maybe wouldn't because it sounds
a little crazy not really honestly it
doesn't sound crazy to me it really
doesn't but I wonder it's like is anyone
else's Behavior now bothering you or
it's like maybe it's just just your
boyfriend that's a good call like is
your mom bothering you yeah co-workers
right are you just like feeling bothered
right take a look at all the other
relationships and see if anything else
has changed but still I would advise do
not make a permanent decision like while
you are in such a transitional period
yeah no that's not good I completely
agree maybe just like stay away from him
yeah you know like go out with the girls
dearest turd and GERD I got out of a
relationship last year after my
boyfriend cheated on me using a dating
app tonight I was swiping as I do and I
came across his profile and it said
active today but I know for a fact that
he has a new girlfriend like he has a
picture of them tagged from yesterday on
his Instagram do I tell her or would
that be like psycho X Behavior I have a
burner Instagram account from college
that I could DM her with so it wouldn't
be me but like should I just let it play
out I left the relationship gracefully
when I shouldn't have so I almost want
to tell her for Revenge purposes even
though it's nothing to do with the new
girlfriend even though I have nothing to
do with the new girlfriend XOXO a
spiteful toaster girl not your circus
not your monkeys like stay out of
just you'll never actually move on if
you're like still dming his new
girlfriend and I get your point but you
do look crazy and just true freedom and
true closure is like not caring and you
need to get to that place yeah and you
literally admitted that you would be
doing it for Revenge not out of like the
goodness of your hearts you're worried
about this girl so you know women are
supporting you could have pretended it
was altruistic and I appreciate that you
didn't yeah also to me like you should
just take this as a sign that you
absolutely did the right thing and like
you are on the right path like that's
the sign from the universe like you're
on the right path thank you Universe
thank you for this take the win no
you're so right instead of like running
with this information why don't you find
solace in this information like you
dodged a bullet like it's still going on
he hasn't learned and not that you
probably ever blamed yourself nor was it
ever your fault but it's like he will do
it to the next person and the next
person like it has nothing to do with
you it had nothing to do with your
relationship or something like you
weren't giving and it's just him and
he's a piece of [__] and like I would
find thousand that I really would that's
so true like let this information heal
you yeah instead of fuel your revenge
yeah and it has restorative properties
it does and it's been a year like we're
moving on we're moving on not my circus
not my monkeys retweet
that was your toasters I feel like each
one the answer was clear like I feel
good about the advice I don't feel like
there was any you know moral dilemmas
like what you do no I feel like
everything we said is 100 facts yeah I
agree it's Crystal Clear what needs to
be done crystal clear
um so again dear toasters the submission
emails deertoesters gmail.com try and
keep your submissions as brief as
possible just like need to know
information and if we've read a
submission of yours in the last couple
of months write us an update how did
things go did you take our advice did
you not did things implode did things
settle like we need to know don't leave
us hanging don't like just take our
advice and like use us and then run no
we like put our lot of ourselves into
this advice like and we're empaths so
until we close the loop on stuff like
it's open
open so true and that's our show you
guys thank you so much for listening to
to uh what's the show called The Toast
the Millennium Morning Show where we
deliver the past five stories that you
need to know every Monday through Friday
on YouTube so if you're watching this on
YouTube please feel free to subscribe
and give this video a thumbs up we're
also available as a podcast anywhere
podcasts can be found so at Spotify
iTunes Stitcher public radio
iheartradiocastbox all the places so
everyone listen to podcast find us the
Chelsea five star review about a
beautiful sounding it's wickedly
talented we are having a great Wednesday
don't forget to hump someone you love
and we will see you tomorrow we're gonna
make it there for the latter half of the
week you guys it's coming up tomorrow
we'll see you in the latter half bye
yeah bye love ya bye